signale von intelligenten außerirdischen
ob er alleine weltraum sind das ist eine
uralte menschheitsfrage und deswegen
hält die menschheit mit vielen
technischen geräten ausschau nach
außerirdischen versucht signale
einzufangen die sich durchs all bewegen
und intelligenten ursprungs sein könnten
wissenschaftler aus kanada sind jetzt
der meinung signale von anderen spezies
entdeckt zu haben damit herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction die
wissenschaftler ermanno bohrer und eric
gauthier von der universität laval in
quebec haben laut eigenen angaben bei
der beobachtung von rund zweieinhalb
millionen sternen bei einigen davon
auffälligkeiten entdeckt genauer gesagt
bei 234 stern dort fanden sie
lichtimpulse die sehr periodisch
erschienen für die beiden astrophysiker
kann es keine andere erklärung geben als
das außerirdische lebensform uns auf
ihre existenz aufmerksam machen wollen
viele wissenschaftler sind sich nach
heutigem wissensstand sicher dass es
weitere spezies mit technologie
kenntnissen da draußen geben muss bei
der hohen anzahl der potenziellen
planeten auf den leben entstehen könnte
soll die wahrscheinlichkeit einfach zu
groß seien zur berechnung benutzt man
übrigens die drake gleichung diese wurde
1961 entwickelt und mit ihr sollen man
berechnen können wie hoch die
wahrscheinlichkeit von intelligentem
leben im all ist warum gibt es bisher
eigentlich keine wirkliche beweise für
eine fortgeschrittene zivilisation
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems
wenn eine spezies technologisch weit
genug fortgeschritten ist um den eigenen
planeten und das eigene system zu
verlassen wäre die besiedlung der
restlichen milchstraße experten zufolge
nur eine frage von wenigen millionen
jahren bei dem alter der galaxis stehen
auch hier die chancen eigentlich hoch
das wird vermieter dogs on genannt
benannt nach dem physik nobelpreisträger
enrico fermi der sich in den 1950 er
jahren mit dieser frage
auseinandergesetzt hat also von den
zahlen her ist es möglich dass
außerirdische da draußen sind aber wir
sehen nichts davon das kann auch zum
beispiel aber daran liegen dass wir nach
den falschen signalen suchen aktuell hat
der britische physiker brian cox eine
theorie aufgestellt weshalb wir noch
nichts von anderen intelligenten
lebensform mitbekommen haben
diesen sei ihre hohe entwicklungsstufe
zum verhängnis geworden
die technologie hätte die außerirdischen
dazu gebracht sich selbst zu vernichten
ähnliches könnte auch der menschheit
drohen denn wir verfügen schon lange
über das wissen und die ausreichende
anzahl an atomwaffen die verheerend
genug sind um die gesamte menschheit zu
vernichten cox sieht den grund für eine
potentielle ausrottung außerirdischer
lebensformen aber nicht nur in der
entwicklung von waffen sondern auch in
der veränderung des klimas ebenfalls
ausgelöst durch die technologie also
bisher keine signale weil sich die
außerirdischen selbst vernichtet haben
könnten jetzt signale aufgetaucht sein
die das gegenteil beweisen
die these der beiden wissenschaftler die
sie in einem artikel im fachmagazin
publications aus astronomical society of
the pacific dargelegt haben muss erst
noch bestätigt werden dabei muss
natürlich auch bedacht werden dass die
signale von schon vor sehr langer zeit
gesendet worden sind und die
zivilisation die könnten natürlich dort
schon nicht mehr existieren zu den
theorien wie viel leben es da draußen
geben könnte existiert natürlich auch
einige davon ausgeht dass wir alleine
mal sind die world report asse die geht
davon aus dass es sehr sehr viele
zufälle gebraucht hat damit sich auf der
erde hier leben bilden konnte abstand
zur sonne größe des mondes
beschaffenheit des magnetfeldes usw
dadurch sei die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
dies auf anderen planeten genauso
passieren könnte verschwindend gering
andere wissenschaftler sind der meinung
dass es niedere lebensform ja außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems geben könnte
allerdings sei die weiterentwicklung zu
einer intelligenten lebensform viel zu
unwahrscheinlich
passend zum heutigen thema haben wir
eine hörbuch empfehlung für euch das
hörbuch nachrichten aus einem
unbekannten universum bekommt ihr über
unseren link kostenlos zum ort liebl
probeabo
mit dazu also geschenk den link findet
ihr hier
unter dem i und natürlich auch in der
video beschreibung falls euch das video
gefallen hatte lasse mir gerne einen
daumen nach oben da und ein kostenloses
abo einfach hier klicken
und wenn ihr hier klickt kommt ihr zu
einem weiteren spannenden video wo es um
außerirdisches leben in unserem
sonnensystem geht also
es existieren eine menge ideen und
theorien über möglichkeiten zu
außerirdischen leben aber was sagt ihr
dazu könnten das wirklich signale von
außerirdischen sein und was haltet ihr
von der theorie
dass sich alle hochentwickelten spezies
im all irgendwann selbst auslöschen
die diskussion die interessiert mich
sehr also bis dann bleibt dran